we are ready to offer highly aebischer
trade he has two power plants pilar ordis
partnership including 0 taris 1 0
haas rating all good things are a single market
of a real d'infiniti millions
pebble beach free trade agreement in
services sector formwork ranging from
business services  telecommunications
will have a variant to have such a service
we also looking to include j title trade
in tech the intellectual property
respective accessories public
procurement markets we are ready to
offer jce even though we know there will
be strong competition showcase of uk
have immediate n  is that one of them
in the future competition is not because
of a world geographical economic proximity
interdependence in warcraft
man died also guys screaming
exceptional artists offered and conditioners
men at least two things first we need
to machu compete is and women's
open  in doing we have agreed minister
johnson to have future by chip will
deprive a die side by side in iron
competitive advantage
yes ms. asnar the grid in specific
guaranteed workforce customs on the verrines
field over long turn over of the NGO
turn timing mechanism all ap
aude de hay stand up yes with sochaux
environmental climate tax and state aid
matters all of a hymn of the future
developments to have fled very citrus
mastin cloud a citrus fisheries 10 to
green shoots provide strong continue besides
reciprocal
haiti procure access to market and to work with teboul quotas
at as it was that anna gray hanif asuel
to jeanne arbus commitment to world level
playing  field and sisters in force may 24
relative to the verrie indices us free
and fair trade agreement
we will have to separate markets instead
of one single market roll origin
a strong cast marri this will hayes
between the uk a mourning or accept
newmarket will  be subject to
certification market authorization a
supra region activities of will be no
harmonization future vehicle nissan
open ten thousand  examples financial
times will know length of passporting
rights the used to enjoy under the union
legislation all-in door with good or
secret services
you will need to comply with 2 red hihou
by and safety of their standaard
protecting art of public policy
objective
we  also want to have economic partnership
du cobra many other aerial mobility of
people to carriers consider themselves
at o2 uk listening continue to participate in the
program this alone has risen europe
or erasmus for this love you will need
for speed clarity and its own multi and
you'll  find framework billon 28 want is
you will consider whether economic
partnership for
mike weaver's bea company below at financial
services euse adequacy o2 uk d'entrée
protection of origin 18 bis unilateral
of the six young people out of 10 or of the few our
draft shares  mend arrived around the
23 two future openers the chains chip
lead to be considered in the light star
of assessment works and immediate riaz and
any
future cooperation with the united kingdom in terms of
internal security must in our view
respect three conditions which are
also not surprising
the first is that the united kingdom must
undertake to apply the
european convention on human rights  the
second is that the great British
will have to put in place adequate standards
of data protection this
is a fundamental concern
for Europeans and to which the
European Parliament will remain very attentive
and thirdly any cooperation
should be subject to a
settlement mechanism  of
disputes and where the partnership is
based on concepts derived from European law
obviously the European court of justice
must be able to continue to play its role to the
full
we also want lasting cooperation
on foreign policy
security defense to which we
are working and we will work in
close cooperation with the High
Representative  joseph bourrel
it is a question of protecting our countries against
external threats
it is also a question and therefore of
quickly having a framework that
allows us to work to cooperate
to discuss together on the management of
conflicts the promotion of peace and
of security
for this we need
mechanisms for dialogue, consultation,
exchange of information and
cooperation mechanism which will have
to fully respect the autonomy and
sovereignty of the union
the autonomy and sovereignty of
the united kingdom
marion ambitious requires a
robust framework to guarantee its implementation
over time its credibility and therefore its
implementation by both parties
beyond the mechanisms of dialogue and
political consultation
we need a toolbox
made up of
effective dispute resolution mechanisms  and
implementation this course of governance must
cover all areas of
economic cooperation and security
if certain obligations  ons are not
respected by one of the two parties
the other party must be able to act
quickly and effectively, including in
our eyes with autonomous measures in the
event of violation of the essential elements
of the agreement